mes chers concitoyens mesdames et
messieurs nous nous retrouvons pour
faire un point régulier sur la situation
sanitaire de notre pays et sur les
moyens que nous nous donnons pour
réussir ensemble à y faire face
cette situation vous le savez reste
particulièrement fragile
chaque jour la france enregistre une
moyenne de vingt mille nouvelles
contaminations et 1600 nouvelles
hospitalisations avec hélas 320
personnes décédées
ces chiffres nous pourrions finir par
nous habituer soyons cependant
conscients qu'ils sont très élevés et se
traduisent par une pression majeure et
qui ne faiblit pas sur nos structures
hospitalières
aujourd'hui si malade sur dix
accueillies dans nos services de
réanimation sont des malades de l'aco
vide ce qui oblige nombre de nos
hôpitaux a des qualités soins moins
urgent pour libérer des lits
je veux à nouveau saluer l'engagement
remarquable des soignants qui reste
totalement mobilisée malgré la fatigue
accumulée
j'étais encore hier à leurs côtés avec
olivier vers ans dans un établissement
d'île de france et je ne cesserai de me
préoccuper de leur mission et de leurs
conditions de travail
si la situation reste préoccupante
elle se distingue néanmoins de celle de
beaucoup de nos voisins nous n'avons pas
connu au cours des dernières semaines de
nouvelles vagues épidémiques d'ampleur
nos chiffres sont certes élevé mais ils
sont relativement stables
le taux de mortalité par habitant liait
au virus
c'est au cours de cette deuxième vague
l'un des plus bas d'europe
la circulation du virus n'a pas
sensiblement augmenté au cours des deux
dernières semaines
le taux de positivité des tests restent
globalement stables
cela s'explique très largement par les
efforts par les effets pardon de la
stratégie que nous avons adoptées au
cours des derniers mois sous l'autorité
du président de la république et après
l'avoir soumise au parlement
nous n'avons pas attendu pour prendre
des mesures strictes
dès la fin du mois d'octobre dernier
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas les
lever complètement quand nos chiffres se
sont améliorés en fin d'année nous avons
su nous adapter dès les premiers signes
d'un début de reprise épidémique au
début du mois de janvier notamment en
avançant la mesures de couvre-feu à 18
heures d'abord dans certains
départements puis à l'échelle nationale
notre stratégie a été graduée
elle s'est adapté en permanence à
l'évolution de la situation tout en
restant responsable et cohérente dans la
durée elle nous a permis de garder
encore aujourd'hui le contrôle de
l'épidémie
tout en préservant au mieux la vie
sociale et économique de notre pays
ainsi selon les toutes dernières
estimations publiées par l'insee cet
après midi le niveau d'activité
s'établit aujourd'hui à 4% sous la
normale ce ralentissement économique est
moins marqué que ce que vivent
actuellement beaucoup de nos voisins
soumis à la même épée démis ses
résultats au delà des mesures que nous
avons prises tiennent aussi et surtout à
la grande vigilance dans chacune et
chacun de vous faites preuve au
quotidien comme ce fut le cas lors des
fêtes de fin d'année qui ne se sont pas
traduites par la flambée épidémique que
nous pouvions craindre cela est riche
d'enseignements car moins que jamais
nous ne devons baisser la garde
nous faisons face vous le savez à
l'apparition d'un nouveau risque celui
de la propagation des nouvelles souches
du virus que l'on appelle les variants
ces variants 10 anglais sud africains
brésiliens pour désigner les zones où
ils ont été repérés sont beaucoup plus
contagieux que le virus classique il se
propage donc plus vite touche davantage
de personnes et peuvent conduire à des
flambées épidémiques comme celles qui
ont frappé nos amis britanniques
irlandais ou portugais
ces variants ne constitue pas une menace
potentielle mais bien réel ils sont déjà
présents sur notre territoire et
progresse en terme de 10
lyon nous le mesurons régulièrement
grâce au système de suivi que nous avons
mis en place en quelques semaines la
part des malades atteints par ces
nouvelles formes du virus est passé
d'environ 3,3 pour cent le 8 janvier à
14 % aujourd'hui
selon les estimations avec des taux
encore supérieur dans certaines régions
c'est pourquoi je voulais dit vendredi
dernier
l'émergence de ce nouveau risque nous a
conduit à nous interroger sur
l'opportunité de mettre en place un
troisième confinement le confinement
nous en connaissons en effet
l'efficacité au plan sanitaire que ce
soit au printemps dernier où au mois de
novembre
il a permis de freiner fortement
l'épidémie mais le confinement nous en
connaissons aussi le co économique
social humain et parfois même sanitaires
nous savons tous aussi que plus le temps
passe plus les mesures de restriction se
succèdent et plus leur impact est
difficile à supporter nous mesurons tous
les risques psychosociaux qui
s'accumulent et auquel il nous
appartient de veiller très sérieusement
et puis ayant bien conscience qu'un
confinement si on le souhaite
efficace signifierait très concrètement
la fermeture de beaucoup de nos
commerces mais aussi potentiellement
c'est de nos établissements
d'enseignement
à l'instar de ce qu'ont fait la plupart
des pays voisins la france
l'unesco vient de le reconnaître fait
partie des pays qui sont parvenus à
maintenir les écoles ouvertes le plus
possible depuis le début de l'épidémie
je vous le dis ce choix et toutes les
conséquences qui l'a entraîné pour nos
enfants d'abord pour la vie économique
et sociale de la nation ensuite est à
mettre à l'honneur de notre pays et de
toute la communauté éducative à qui je
veux exprimer ma reconnaissance et mon
profond attachement
c'est pourquoi un nouveau confinement ne
peut s'envisager qu'en tout dernier
recours
la situation ne justifie pas à ce jour
notre niveau d'incidence est certes
v mais il reste encore très inférieur à
ce qu'il était en octobre dernier alors
même que nous dépistons toujours autant
vous disant cela je veux être clair si
nous y sommes contraints en cas de
dégradation forte et rapide de la
situation
nous n'hésiterions pas à prendre nos
responsabilités l'objectif que nous
devons nous fixer ce n'est pas de
retarder cette échéance c'est de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour l'éviter j'en
appelle à la mobilisation des françaises
et des français
nous devons tenir ensemble nous devons
agir ensemble
plus que jamais nous avons engagé une
course contre la montre avec cette
épidémie
tant que la vaccination n'aura pas
produit ses pleins effets et chaque jour
compte et nous devons nous battre pied à
pied grâce aux armes dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui
d'abord en maintenant les mesures de
restrictions qui sont en vigueur
beaucoup de secteurs font l'objet de
fermeture ou de limitation et le moment
n'est pas venu de les alléger
je sais parfaitement que ces mesures
sont particulièrement difficiles à vivre
pour chacune et chacun d'entre vous et
tout particulièrement pour les acteurs
les salariés les professionnels des
secteurs qui n'ont pu reprendre leur
activité ou encore pour les étudiants de
l'enseignement supérieur je mesure et je
partage pleinement le désarroi et
l'impatience
car ce qu'ils veulent ce n'est pas
d'abord être indemnisés ce n'est pas
restée ces jeux c'est de pouvoir
travailler je le sais je le comprends
mais cela n'est pas encore possible car
l'heure n'est pas au relâchement de nos
efforts l'heure est au respect maximale
de nos règles communes
ces règles l'immense majorité d'entre
nous les respecte mais il suffit qu'un
faible nombre s'en affranchissent pour
que le virus
prosper causant parfois des conséquences
irrémédiables en raison de l'attitude
irresponsable de quelques-uns
il ne s'agit pas là d'une affaire de
discipline simplement mais tout
simplement de respect des autres et de
solidarité
l'heure est au renforcement de nos
mesures chaque fois que cela est
nécessaire chaque fois que cela permet
de réduire le risque est d'être plus
efficace dans la lutte contre le virus
c'est le sens des décisions que je vous
ai annoncé vendredi dernier qu'ils
s'appliquent depuis quelques jours
premièrement la fermeture des frontières
pour empêcher les variants de pénétrer
sur notre territoire
depuis dimanche les déplacements à
destination ou en provenance des pays
étrangers extérieurs à l'union
européenne sont désormais interdits sauf
motif impérieux
pourquoi une telle mesure nous devons
empêcher que des personnes porteuses
d'un variante liste arrivée en france et
cela commence par éviter d'aller se
contaminer à l'étranger il ne s'agit
évidemment pas d'empêcher nos
concitoyens qui sont aujourd'hui en
déplacement à l'étranger de revenir chez
eux
il s'agit en revanche d'arrêter tous les
déplacements qui ne répondent pas à une
nécessité absolue
et c'est notamment le cas de tous les
voyages touristiques pour entrer en
france depuis un pays de l'union
européenne il faut vous le savez
désormais présenter un test pcr négatif
que l'on arrive par avion train bateau
ou par la route
en parallèle de cette mesure de
fermeture des frontières les
déplacements en direction ou en
provenance de nos territoires
d'outre-mer sont également concernés par
l'interdiction de tout déplacement sauf
motif impérieux nous ne le faisons pas
pour nous protéger cette fois ci d'un
risque accru dans ces territoires car
l'épidémie
il circule encore très modérément mais
au contraire pour les protéger d'un
risque de contamination en provenance de
la métropole ou de l'étranger comme le
montre la situation de mayotte qui a été
durement frappée par le variant sud
africain et où nous avons décidé
aujourd'hui d'une mesure de confinement
généralisée j'ai conscience que toutes
ces restrictions sont difficiles à vivre
surtout quand il s'agit de renoncer à
des projets de voyage ou de déplacement
mais c'est indispensable
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin revient
à tout à l'heure sur les mesures que
nous prenons pour assurer la mise en
oeuvre de nos contrôles aux frontières
ainsi que sur le renforcement de nos
contrôles de manière générale
deuxième mesure vous le savez encore la
fermeture des grands centres commerciaux
qui constituent des lieux de forte
concentration et de brassage nous avons
tous vu des images de ces centres bondée
où les distances ne peuvent pas être
respecté et les risques suffisamment
maîtrisé nous avons également renforcé
les georges dans les commerces de plus
de 400 mètres carrés
nous veillerons évidemment à ce que les
salariés des propriétaires des 25000
commerces concernés soit accompagnée sur
le plan économique et social comme nous
l'avons fait depuis le début de la crise
pour tous les secteurs économiques
concernés
troisième mesure le renforcement du
télétravail
il s'agirait en réalité d'un levier très
puissant que nous n'utilisons pas
suffisamment pour freiner l'épidémie
le développement du télétravail est un
enjeu de fonds et de long terme dont les
partenaires sociaux se sont saisis dans
le cadre d'un accord qu'ils ont conclue
en fin d'année dernière et qu'il leur
appartient de décliner progressivement
dans les entreprises mais la crise
sanitaire exige de prendre des
dispositions urgentes et exceptionnel
télétravail est partout où c'est
possible devient impérative or depuis la
fin de l'année
le recours au travail s'est réduit ces
qui est d'autant plus regrettable que
beaucoup d'entreprises n'avait pas
déployé toutes les possibilités dans le
faire il ya encore trop de milieux
professionnels ou le télétravail serait
possible mais n'existe pas du tout à des
niveaux très faibles les administrations
publiques doivent en particulier montrer
l'exemple et j'y veillerai elisabeth
bornes reviendra dans quelques instants
sur ce sujet très important
quatrième mesure le recours aux tests et
à un isolement strictes il y avoue le
savent et quasiment pas de grip ce
moment c'est une des bonnes nouvelles de
l'épidémie si vous avez de la fièvre des
maux de tête
la probabilité que vous ayez l'aco vide
et
donc grande au moindre doute faites vous
tester nous disposons en france d'une
capacité de test parmi les plus
développés et les plus accessibles de
tous les pays européens les tests sont
gratuits disponibles à côté de chez vous
et vous aurez un résultat en moins de 24
heures aux 20000 personnes qui sont
détectés positifs chaque jour je le
redis isolé vous immédiatement ne sortez
pas de chez vous pendant sept jours et
des l'assurance maladie à identifier les
personnes avec lesquelles vous avez été
en contact accepté la visite à domicile
d'un infirmier libéral qui vous est
désormais proposée et permettra de
tester vos proches à cet effet nous
allons amplifier dès la semaine
prochaine
le déploiement de cette stratégie testez
alerté protéger olivier et veyran vous
présentera dans quelques instants la
nouvelle organisation que nous avons
mises en place pour gagner encore en
efficacité dans la détection du virus
est remontée ces chaînes de
contamination comme on dit avec une
vigilance redoublée
quand nous identifiant des cas positifs
liés aux nouveaux variants cette
mobilisation générale pour freiner
l'épidémie
nous devons la tenir tout le temps
nécessaire pour que la vaccination
destiné à protéger d'abord les plus
vulnérables et les plus exposés à la
maladie est produit c'est meilleur effet
la campagne de vaccination a commencé il
ya maintenant plus d'un mois
la route est encore longue mais nous
avons déjà atteint et même dépassé les
premiers objectifs que nous nous étions
fixés
un million et demi de vaccination ont
été réalisées en janvier au lieu d'1
millions prévus initialement
il est exact que d'autres pays ont
démarré plus rapidement que nous mais
cela résulte d'un choix que nous
assumons nous avons commencé par les
publics pour lesquels la mise en oeuvre
de la vaccination est en effet la plus
délicate la plus longue
les résidents des ehpad et des unités de
soins de longue durée
mais ce sont aussi des plus fragiles
plus de vingt trois mille d'entre eux
sont décédés depuis le début de
l'épidémie soit près d'un tiers des 17
auto alors qu'ils ne représentent que 1%
de la population française d'ici la fin
de la semaine tous les résidents
volontaires des ehpad auront reçu leur
première injection 70 % de cette
population aura franchi cette première
étape décisive dans quelques jours et
elle sera totalement protégées d'ici le
début du mois de mars
à l'issue des deuxième injection
c'est un taux d'adhésion remarquable
preuve que notre stratégie dans ces
établissements était la bonne
le temps que nous avons pris début
janvier pour accompagner nos aînés vers
la vaccination était important il a
porté ses fruits
la vaccination est certes une course de
vitesse mais elle ne doit pas se faire
au détriment de la qualité de la
sécurité et surtout de l'adhésion de nos
concitoyens pour atteindre pour chacune
des priorités vaccinale le pourcentage
le plus élevé de personnes effectivement
vaccinés nous assumons à ce titre de
respecter le délai de trois à quatre
semaines entre les deux injections des
vaccins feiler et moderna contrairement
à d'autres pays certes peu nombreux qui
ont cherché à vacciner un maximum de
personnes en décalant à plus tard leurs
appels dont dépend pourtant l'efficacité
finale de la protection vaccinale
nous ne ferons pas ce choix périlleux
sur le plan sanitaire et qui peut coûter
cher à moyen terme
la confiance est là de plus en plus de
français veulent se faire vacciner
nous pouvons nous en réjouir mais la
partie n'est pas encore gagnée
la campagne de vaccination suis
désormais un rythme soutenu très soutenu
nous avons vacciné hier et aujourd'hui
plus de cent mille personnes chaque jour
dont près de 70 mille ans première
injection
il s'agit d'accélérer encore en
direction de trois publics
particulièrement prioritaire
les personnes de plus de 75 ans les
personnes atteintes d'une pathologie
grave et bien sûr nos soignants auquel
nous devons une attention particulière
car ils sont plus que les autres exposés
au risque est que nous avons plus que
jamais besoin d'eux pour assurer la
prise en charge des malades
la mobilisation je vous le dis vous le
savez remarquable professionnels de
santé à l'hôpital et en ville
agen des agences régionales de santé des
préfectures collectivités territoriales
associations tous sont mobilisés pour
relever ce défi dans chaque centre
il y en a aujourd'hui environ un millier
en activité une équipe s'est constituée
souvent autour du maire dans un dialogue
constant et exigeant avec les
représentants de l'état
je tiens ici à les remercier vivement
la campagne repose sur eux deux millions
deux rendez vous ont d'ores et déjà été
pris pour autant je n'ignore rien des
difficultés qui ont été rencontrés
la principale d'entre elles est là étant
liée à la déprogrammation de rendez vous
lier un retard de livraisons de doses
par les laboratoires en dépit des
communs de contractualiser par l'union
européenne nous nous engageons à la plus
grande transparence centre par centre
territoire par territoire pour donner le
plus de visibilité possible au
déploiement de cette campagne vaccinale
mais comme les dernières semaines l'ont
montré la campagne de vaccination dépend
des livraisons des laboratoires et nous
oblige à nous adapter
c'est la raison pour laquelle la france
et l'europe agisse pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements un vaccin déployer la
production sur le territoire national et
prévoir les étapes ultérieures
la ministre délégué à l'industrie agnès
pannier une hache y reviendra dans un
instant je mesure aussi parfaitement
l'angoissent de toutes ces personnes
âgées de plus de 65 15 ans qui n'ont pas
encore obtenu un rendez vous de la
famille qui les aide dans leurs
démarches ou qui attendent
patiemment et parfois avec anxiété dans
les rappels et qu'on leur donne des
réponses
c'est pourquoi je veux vous annoncer que
nous allons ouvrir dans les prochains
jours 1,7 million de rendez vous
supplémentaire pour des premières
injections 500000 rendez vous fin
février qui seront ouverts à compter de
demain et un million deux cent mille
rendez vous sur le mois de mars qui
seront ouverts dès le milieu de la
semaine prochaine
ces nouveaux rendez vous permettront de
répondre
un grand nombre de demandes en attente
et seront suivis encore d'au moins 500
milles rendez vous supplémentaire sur le
mois de mars que nous ouvriront
progressivement d'ici là une fois
confirmé les dates définitives de
livraison d'ici avril
nous atteindrons ainsi l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république
d'avoir proposer la vaccination à toutes
les personnes de plus de 75 ans
volontaire et il faut qu'elles soient
les plus nombreuses possibles ainsi
qu'aux personnes de moins de 75 ans
atteinte de comorbidités graves
par ailleurs nous gardons pour objectif
de proposer la vaccination à toutes les
personnes de plus de 65 ans d'ici le
mois de mai est d'avoir couvert tous les
français adulte d'ici la fin de l'été
s'agissant plus spécifiquement des
personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans et
présentant des comorbidités les rendant
plus vulnérables à la maladie
je vous rappelle qu'elles peuvent d'ores
et déjà se faire vacciner si elles ont
l'une des affections pathologie parmi
les plus graves qui figure sur le site
du ministère de la santé
enfin comme vous le savez la haute
autorité de santé a autorisé hier
l'utilisation d'un nouveau vaccin en
france le vaccin
astrazeneca cela va nous permettre
d'accélérer le rythme de vaccination
grâce à ce nouveau vaccin nous pourrons
atteindre l'objectif de 4 millions de
personnes ayant reçu leur première
injection d'ici
la fin du mois de février conformément à
l'avis de la haute autorité en santé
ce vaccin sera utilisé pour vacciner
d'abord l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé quel que soit leur âge
puis les personnes de 50 à 65 ans ayant
des comorbidités enfin l'ensemble des
personnes de 50 à 65 ans la première
livraison de vaccins
astrazeneca dès la fin de cette semaine
sera affecté aux établissements de santé
pour protéger les professionnels de
santé hospitaliers et de villes qui se
battent en première ligne contre le
virus et la vaccination
je vous l'annoncé devrait commencer dès
ce samedi les conditions de conservation
de ce vaccin moins complexe que les deux
premiers nous permettront de confier
ensuite d'ici la fin de ce mois aux
professionnels de santé de ville médecin
généraliste pharmaciens et infirmiers la
suite de cette campagne vaccinale
ils ont toute votre confiance pour cela
et cela nous permettra de renforcer
encore la proximité de cette campagne
vaccinale
j'invite le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé olivier ferrand à
approfondir en particulier notre
nouvelle politique de dépistage
ce ministre monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs on parle souvent du
triptyque tester alerté protéger je
voudrais aujourd'hui mettre des images
des chiffres du vécu derrière ce pilier
incontournable de notre stratégie contre
l'épidémie
vous le savez la france est depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
l'un des pays qui réalise le plus de
tests de dépistage co-lead songer un
instant que près de quatre tests sont
réalisés chaque seconde dans notre pays
dans l'un des douze mille points
existants permettant de se faire tester
grâce à l'incroyable mobilisation des
laboratoires des techniciens de
laboratoire des biologistes des médecins
des pharmaciens des infirmières parce
que nous avons fait le choix de laisser
l'accès aux tests totalement libre
c'est-à-dire sans ordonnance et sans
reste à charge ce que pour le coup nous
sommes l'un des seuls pays au monde
affaire après une rentrée scolaire que
vous savez difficile au mois de
septembre synonyme de délais d'attentes
nous avons mis tous les moyens pour
faciliter l'accès à ces tests
priorisation des personnes symptomatique
large déploiement des tests antigénique
ont permis d'améliorer rapidement et
constamment la situation il vous prendra
en moyenne une demi journée entre le
moment où vous voudrez être testé le
moment où ce test sera réalisé et dans
92% des cas vous aurez le résultat du
test dans les 24 heures et même dans les
20 minutes
si vous procédez par des tests
antigénique nous allons désormais plus
loin
nous allons multiplier les opérations
collectives de dépistage notables
notamment en direction des
établissements scolaires en lien avec
jean michel blanquer remet également des
universités en lien avec frédéric vidal
de manière à renforcer l'acceptabilité
du test qui peut ne pas être agréable
quand on est petit nous attendons l'avis
de la haute autorité de santé sous dix
jours qui nous permettra d' employer des
techniques de prélèvement nouvelle par
prélèvement salivaire dans des
conditions que la haute autorité de
santé devra préciser sans attendre nous
nous équiperons et nous déploierons ces
techniques pour que retour des vacances
scolaires nous puissions réaliser
plusieurs centaines de milliers de tests
par prélèvement salivaire
seule la technique de prélèvement change
oublié dans ce cas là les coûts villon
dans le nez on prélève de la salive
en revanche l'examen se poursuit ensuite
en laboratoire de la même manière que
pour les tests que vous connaissez je le
redis nous ciblerons en priorité les
enfants et des personnes qui ne peuvent
pas bien supporté les tests par
prélèvement nasopharyngé classique en
revanche les tests salivaires rapide
in an est parfois question on peut être
interrogés ce serait formidable si on
pouvait disposer de tests salivaires qui
vous rendent un résultat en quelques
minutes mais à ce stade les études qui
sont pas très nombreuses ne sont pas
favorables à l'utilisation de ces tests
parce que la sensibilité des tests qui
existe aujourd'hui est trop faible
si votre test est positif vient alors le
moment de vous alerter c'est ce qu'on
appelle le contact racing c'est à dire
l'identification des personnes alertées
autour de vous que vous auriez pu
contaminer mais aussi la recherche des
personnes qui ont pu
vous contaminer sans que vous le sachiez
et pour de manière elle aussi à les
alerter
nous renforçons continuellement les
moyens humains et techniques dans les
agences régionales de santé au sein de
l'assurance maladie
ces milliers de personnes formées qui
vous appelle dans les 24 heures dans 93%
des cas et vous permettre de prévenir
pour les personnes que vous auriez pu
contaminer afin qu'elle soit également
et dans les mêmes délais alertés à leur
tour et bien sûr l'application tous
antique au bide téléchargées par près de
13 millions de français et qui a déjà
permis d'alerter 60 7000 cas contacts
potentiels
là aussi nous allons plus loin désormais
pour agir plus vite plus fort via la
mobilisation de médiateurs de lutte anti
qu'ovide qu'ils sont capables de faire
du 3 en 1 vous testez initiés
immédiatement sur place
ce fameux contact racing et vous guider
dans votre mise à l'abri
vient ensuite le troisième temps du
pilier du triptyque la mise à l'abri
isolement des cas dont le test des
personnes dans le test est positif ainsi
que les cas contactez nous avons depuis
le premier jour vous le savez fait le
choix de la confiance plutôt que le
choix de la contrainte et de
l'accompagnement des personnes dans leur
isolement de sept jours parce que
parfois ça peut poser des difficultés de
se retrouver chez soi d'ordre sanitaire
ou d'ordre social ou les deux depuis le
10 janvier je rappelle que toute
personne positive qu'à contacter ou cas
symptomatique dans la tente d'un
résultat de test qui doit être effectué
dans les 48 heures peut se déclarer via
l'assurance maladie et bénéficier d'un
arrêt de travail avec une prise en
charge complète sans jour de carence
avec indemnisation
c'est un système qui est efficace trente
mille français ont fait appel à cette
télé déclaration en ligne sur le site de
l'assurance maladie
plus de dix mille d'entre elles ont
déclaré à la positivité de leurs tests
réalisés dans les 48 heures signes que
nous avons raison de faire confiance à
l'esprit de responsabilité des français
d'ailleurs nous menons des contrôles par
l'assurance maladie sans que ne soit
remonté de situations anormales à ce
stade
vous êtes accompagné si vous êtes mis à
l'abri contacté dans les 24 heures vous
l'êtes à nouveau à chaque fois que la
situation l'exigé
pendant les 7 jours qui suivent nous
allons là encore plus loin en vous
proposant depuis le 20 janvier la visite
d'une infirmière libérale ou d'un
infirmier libéral chez vous de manière à
répondre à vos questions
vérifiez que vous ne manquer de rien
tester si besoin les personnes qui
partagent votre foyer
dès la première semaine plus de 16 mille
visites ont été réalisées par des
soignants au domicile des personnes en
isolement et si vous êtes
particulièrement isolé sachez que vous
pouvez aussi compter sur le soutien
l'appui de quelques 1500 travailleurs
sociaux avec l'appui de vos communes de
vos départements
qu'il s'agisse d'organiser le portage
des repas chez vous de vous aider dans
vos courses ou pour la garde de vos
enfants pour vous proposer un
hébergement si les conditions de votre
logement ne permettent pas de vous
isoler du reste de votre foyer
pour vous accompagner et pourquoi pas
dans vos démarches administratives et
évidemment lorsque nécessaire lorsque
c'est nécessaire vous apporter du
soutien psychologique dans cette période
difficile
je crois pouvoir dire que nous n'avons
rien à envier à nos voisins en matière
de tester alerté protéger avant de
conclure je vais vous parler de la
manière dont nous gérons cette menace
réelle et qu'il faut prendre très au
sérieux vous l'avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre
et comment nous justement nous
implémentons nous améliorerons encore se
tester alertée protéger dans le cadre
des variants ces fameux variant du virus
qui circulent sur notre territoire
je vous ai déjà parlé lors d'une
précédente conférence de presse un peu
plus en détails du variant dit
britannique qui a la particularité
d'être plus contagieux mais a priori pas
plus grave même si certaines études
anglaises suggèrent que la pression
sanitaire pourrait être un peu plus
importante
les variantes sud africaine est la
variante brésilienne nous inquiète
encore davantage d'abord parce qu'il
existe moins de données sur les
infections qu'ils entraînent ensuite
parce que certaines études tendent à
montrer qu'il ya davantage de
réinfection et enfin parce que nous
manquons d'éléments pour être pleinement
sûr que les vaccins seraient par exemple
aussi efficace sur ces variants que sur
le coronavirus que
connaissons habituellement dans notre
pays nous faisons très attention je vous
le disais d'autant que nous avons
objective et monsieur premier est ce que
vous l'avez dit des quatre variants
essentiellement du variant d'origine
anglaise lui on a toutes les raisons de
penser que le vaccin est efficace et qui
ne donne pas je le disais plus de formes
graves mais nous identifions aussi du
variant d'origine suite à une
sud-africaine est depuis hier quatre cas
de variants d'origine brésilienne
notamment dans le var dans la région
aura ainsi qu'à la réunion
notre objectif est clair nous voulons
limiter au maximum la diffusion de ces
variants gagner du temps pour pouvoir
vacciner et protéger les plus fragiles
d'entre nous la stratégie est au fond la
même mais les moyens je le disais que
nous mettons en oeuvre sont encore plus
importants moyens diagnostiques d'abord
avec des nouveaux kits et cr dit
multiplex qui permettent de traquer la
présence d'un variant lorsqu'un test pcr
est positif mais aussi avec le
séquençage génétique massif des tests
positifs qui nous permet de suivre leur
évolution
c'est ainsi que nous savons que 14% des
cas positifs correspondent à des
variantes pour l'essentiel d'origine
anglaise
une fois diagnostiquée un patient
atteint de variants et contacter sans
aucun délai par des professionnels qui
sont spécialement formés de façon à
identifier les conditions de leur
contamination et identifier les cas
contacts et enfin protéger tout le monde
est cassé les chaînes de contamination
tout va ensuite très vite
d'abord pour garantir l'isolément des
personnes avec cette fois ci la
programmation systématique d'un passage
d'un infirmier ou d'une infirmière au
domicile du patient et l'activation
automatique de ce qu'on appelle les
cellules territoriales d'appui l
isolement pour vérifier que les
conditions permettent de garantir cet
isolement dans de bonnes situations
à la fin des sept jours d'isolement la
personne devra encore pendant sept jours
complémentaires limiter le plus possible
ses contacts porter un masque
chirurgical et être particulièrement
attentive à tous les détails dans un
certain nombre de situations il est
arrivé qu'un patient revenant de
l'étranger et dont les conditions
d'acceptabilité de la mise à l'abri
n'était pas assurée soit comme la loi
l'autorisé et sur un décret individuel
un arrêté préfectoral individuel me
soucie seulement contre 1 et encore
davantage accompagner
je le redis les variants parce qu'ils
sont plus contagieux sont amenés à
remplacer progressivement le kobe de 19
dans la forme que nous connaissons nous
ne pouvons pas les éradiquer ces
variants parce que par définition il
diffuse dans le monde entier ainsi qu'en
france et ils sont plus contagieux mais
nous ne le céderons aucune once de
terrain
c'est dans une course contre la montre
c'est donc une course contre la montre
que mènent les dizaines de milliers de
professionnels mobilisés sur tout le
territoire national
et c'est une course contre la montre que
vous nous aider à mener en respectant
les gestes barrière en vous faisant
tester au moindre doute en participant
au contact racing lorsque vous êtes
appelés en restant chez vous si vous
êtes malade ou qu'à contacter il n'y a
rien qui relève du détail tout compte
si nous voulons tenir ensemble merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre dit soyez
a été de la santé j'invite gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur à vous
présenter l'application des dispositifs
de contrôle et de protection de notre
pays que nous avons mises en oeuvre
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs pour vally dernier
le premier ministre a annoncé des
mesures supplémentaires au couvre-feu
pour lutter contre l'épidémie
monsieur prémices revient de l'est de
les rappeler et il m'a demandé
d'appliquer une appli coûts rigoureuse
application pardon de ces règles qui je
le sais demande des efforts et des
renoncements pour beaucoup d'entre nous
mais ces efforts ne doivent pas être
ruinée par les dérapages de quelques-uns
et c'est pourquoi dès samedi dernier les
contrôles ont été intensifiés de manière
très significative et continueront de
l'être dans les prochains jours je
voudrais d'ailleurs remercié les préfets
leur équipe les policiers les gendarmes
les policiers municipaux qui mobilisés
dans des proportions renforcée pour
appliquer ces mesures de fermeté sont
tous les jours sur le terrain
il s'agit tout d'abord de règles du
couvre-feu et des contrôles qui
penseraient déplacements entre 18h et 6h
du matin le renforcement de ses
contrôles se traduit immédiatement par
des chiffres le nombre de ces contrôles
a augmenté de 39% le week-end dernier
par rapport au week-end précédent les
verbalisations augmenté de 53%
je rappelle que depuis le début du
couvre-feu c'est à dire le 15 décembre
quasiment 1 9 million de contrôles ont
été faits par les policiers et les
gendarmes et 177 mille amendes ont été
notifiés je rappelle qu'elle s'élève à
125 euros par personne par ailleurs les
nouvelles règles qui s'appliquent aux
commerces comme la limitation de la
fréquentation d'une jauge strict fixé à
10 mètres carrés par client désormais la
fermeture de certains centres
commerciaux ont été particulièrement
contrôlés et continueront de l'être avec
les services du ministère de l'économie
des finances et de la relance des
policiers des gendarmes et des préfets
travail au contrôle de 1964
établissement recevant du public par
exemple qui ont fait l'objet de ce
contrôle ce week-end deux fois plus que
le week-end précédent nous avons encore
pu être témoin avec bruno le maire avait
gagné ce panier d'une trop forte
affluence dans certains commerces
nous l'avons rappelé que l'application
la responsabilité de tous les
responsables de ces commerces pour
appliquer les normes sanitaires dans
leur établissement est très important
les contrôles se tiendront encore ce
week end pour pouvoir le rappeler le mis
l'économie à d'ailleurs annoncé que les
aides seront suspendus dès lors que les
commerces font l'objet d'une fermeture
administrative à la suite des violations
des règles sanitaires surtout j'ai
demandé aux forces de l'ordre d'être
particulièrement vigilants sur le sujet
des fêtes et des restaurants dits plan
destin et en premier lieu de leurs
organisateurs
ces événements de plus en plus fréquents
alors que nous savons qu'il favorise la
diffusion du virus peuvent anéantir tous
les efforts collectifs dans la journée
d'hier par exemple 587 restaurants et
débits de boissons ont été contrôlés
c'était 180 la veille de cette journée
ces contrôles seront encore renforcées
et je voudrais dire qu'ils ont fait
naître une réponse ferme à la fois de la
justice et bien sûr des services
ministère de l'intérieur 190
rassemblements festifs ont été
démantelés par les forces de l'ordre par
exemple et ont conduit à 208
interpellations et 56 156 pardon ont
donné lieu à des poursuites pénales
contrôler la propagation du virus c'est
également et c'est mon deuxième point
contrôlé évidemment nos frontières à la
suite des annonces ce qu'a rappelé
monsieur le premier ministre
toute entrée en france et toute sortie
notre territoire
six nations ou en provenance d'un pays
extérieurs à l'espace européen est
interdite sauf motif impérieux depuis
lundi depuis le début de cette mesure et
services de la police aux frontières que
je voudrais remercier sont pleinement
mobilisés dans les aéroports pour
contrôler ses vols internationaux 7 129
passagers au départ n'ont par exemple
pas été autorisée pendant deux jours à
prendre leur avion parce qu'il ne voyait
j'ai pas avec ces fameux motif impérieux
41 passagers arrivant en france n'ont
pas été admis sur le territoire national
pour des raisons similaires
par ailleurs avec le ministre des
transports monsieur djebbari nous
veillons à ce que les compagnies
aériennes effectuées avec sérieux et
responsabilité le contrôle les motifs de
déplacement et la présentation d'un test
pc à négatif le gouvernement n'a pas
hésité et n'hésitera pas à sanctionner
durement les compagnies aériennes peu
scrupuleuses sur la réalisation de ces
contrôles qui leur incombent en première
intention
avant les contrôles réalisés bien sûr
par la police aux frontières
al'approche de vacances scolaires les
opérations de contrôle les aéroports
souvent particulièrement renforcée à ma
demande
ces mesures sont contraignantes mais
elles produisent des résultats depuis la
mi-janvier les dispositions prises pour
limiter les déplacements internationaux
ont permis de diviser par plus de trois
le flux de passagers des vols en
provenance ou en direction de pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne
nous sommes passés de 65 mille passagers
jour à vingt mille passes à ses
passagers jour ainsi limiter les
brassages de populations qui favorise la
propagation du coronavirus enfin nous
avons considérablement renforcé notre
dispositif aux frontières terrestres
depuis samedi
en effet toute entrée en france à partir
d'un pays de l'union européenne est
conditionné à la présentation d'un test
pcr négatif de -2 72 heures sauf pour
les routiers et les frontaliers
dès le week-end dernier des policiers
des gendarmes se sont déployés à nos
frontières pour contrôler les accès
routiers mais aussi les lignes
ferroviaires internationales
au total c'est quasiment six mille
femmes et hommes de la police nationale
et de la gendarmerie qui sont engagés à
nos frontières terrestres notamment pour
s'assurer que les passagers en
provenance des pays voisins sont en
possession d'un test pcr négatif depuis
lundi 102 mille personnes ont été
contrôlées à ces fronts
r 680 ont été verbalisés d'une amende
pour défaut de tests pcr
je sais que ces contrôles peut faire
naître dans le quotidien notamment pour
les frontaliers des difficultés j'ai eu
des échanges avec mes homologues
notamment mon homologue belge ce matin
afin de les limiter mais ces contrôles
doivent pouvoir continuer de côté ou de
l'autre de la frontière pour limiter
évidemment les arrivées sur notre sol la
période que nous traversons est
évidemment difficile et elle demande des
efforts en premier lieu aux policiers
aux gendarmes et aux services de l'état
que je remercie au français qui pour
l'immense majorité d'entre eux
respectent les règles édictées
seuls ces règles peuvent à ce stade ne
permettent en effet de maîtriser
l'épidémie
elle applique la mobilisation des
services ministère de l'intérieur est
sous l'autorité de monsieur le premier
ministre et continueront aujourd'hui
demain et les autres jours à pouvoir
nous protéger merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
j'invite elisabeth board ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion a
évoqué devant vous le très important
sujet du télétravail
adam la ministre merci monsieur premier
ministre depuis le début du mois de
novembre
le télétravail doit être la règle pour
toutes les activités qui le permettent
cela signifie que si vous pouvez
réaliser toutes vos activités à distance
vous devez être en télétravail cinq
jours sur cinq aujourd'hui près d'un
tiers des actifs en france peuvent
télétravail est facilement et donc
participer à la lutte contre le virus
en télétravail ans il apparaît toutefois
que le recours au télétravail s'érode
progressivement depuis fin novembre
ainsi selon la dernière enquête réalisée
pour le ministère du travail
parmi les actifs pouvant facilement
télétravail et 64 % seulement ont été
travaillés au moins partiellement la
semaine dernière contre 70%
début novembre soit une baisse de 6
points 30% seulement de ceux qui peuvent
aller travailler à 100% le faisait
contre 45% début novembre soit une
baisse de 15 points
je sais que nous demandons un effort
considérable aux salariés et que pour
beaucoup le télétravail est difficile à
vivre
mais nous n'avons pas le choix il faut
nous remobiliser car le télétravail est
un levier essentiel pour limiter la
circulation du virus
une étude récente menée par le
professeur arnaud fontanet indique que
les risques de contamination sont
diminué de 20% pour les personnes qui
sont en télétravail partiel et de 30 %
pour celles qui sont à temps complet
nous n'entendons pas revenir sur les
règles actuelles c'est sur leur
application effective par toutes les
entreprises et par tous les salariés
qu'il est indispensable de progresser
c'est pourquoi je demande à chaque
entreprise de se mobiliser sans délai
sur les deux priorités suivantes
la première c'est de réduire la part des
salariés qui ne télétravail pas du tout
les enquêtes dont nous disposons nous
montre qu'au moins un tiers des salariés
dont les postes sont télétravail à bhl
ne télétravail pas du tout notre
objectif c'est que ces quelques 2,5
millions de salariés se mettent ou se
remettent à télétravailler la deuxième
priorité c'est que des salariés qui
télétravaillent aujourd'hui un deux ou
trois jours par semaine
face au moins un jour de télétravail en
plus chaque jour compte s'agissant des
salariés qui télétravaillent à 100% nous
maintenant la possibilité de revenir sur
le lieu de travail un jour par semaine
pour celles et ceux qui en expriment le
besoin notamment s'ils souffrent
d'isolement
il est important de leur donner des
moments de lien social mais cela doit
rester une soupape en cas de nécessité
par ailleurs une étude réalisée par mon
ministère montrent également un
relâchement plus pop plus prononcée du
télétravail dans certains secteurs
c'est le cas notamment de la banque et
de l'assurance de la communication de
l'informatique des activités
immobilières et juridique
je réunirai donc les branches
professionnelles concernées en début de
semaine prochaine pour m'assurer que les
mesures nécessaires ont été prises
comme toujours le bon équilibre se
définit dans le dialogue social au plus
près du terrain
c'est pourquoi j'appelle tous les chefs
d'entreprise et les représentants des
salariés à organiser des concertations
au sein de chaque entreprise dans les
meilleurs délais j'ai envoyé hier une
lettre de mobilisation en ce sens aux
responsables des principales
organisations patronales et syndicales
pour que ces règles soient bien
appliquées
j'ai demandé à l'inspection du travail
de rester mobilisés depuis le début de
la crise elle a effectué près de 65
mille interventions sur l'application
des règles sanitaires en entreprise les
inspecteurs que je remercie vérifieront
systématiquement la bonne mise en oeuvre
du télétravail
à l'occasion de chaque contrôle je suis
consciente que c'est un gros effort qui
est demandé aux chefs d'entreprise et à
chaque salarié
je rappelle que nous avons lancé une
ligne d'écouté pour les salariés qui
souffrent d'isolement dont le numéro
s'affiche à l'écran mais cet effort est
nécessaire pour lutter contre le virus
tout en préservant la vie économique et
sociale de notre pays
chacun a un rôle à jouer cet ensemble
nous y arriverons je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
j'invite maintenant sur la question
majeure de l'approvisionnement et de la
distribution des vaccins
agnès pannier une hache ministre délégué
à l'industrie à vous donner des
précisions
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs je ferai d'abord
le point sur les commandes et les
livraisons
l'union européenne à ce jour commandée
plus de 2,6 milliards de doses de
vaccins ces commandes sont fermes
ce sont des commandes qui porte sur des
vaccins qui dispose aujourd'hui de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché ou
qui concernent des candidats vaccins
qu'ils pourront obtenir au terme de
leurs processus d'essai clinique une
autorisation
elles sont également assorti d'options
l'essentiel de ces douze jeux le rat
elles ont été sécurisés cet été c'est
près de 90% de ces doses qui ont été
sécurisés cet été par l'union européenne
avec le soutien des 27 états membres la
commission européenne continue à étudier
tous les candidats vaccins susceptibles
d'être fournir rapidement dans des
centres de vaccination
elle vient de conclure deux pré accord
par exemple avec novavax evans neva les
trois premiers vaccins sélectionnés par
l'union européenne c'était donc cet été
à un moment où nous ne disposions
d'aucun élément sur les essais cliniques
ont obtenu une autorisation de mise sur
le marché de l' agence du médicament
européen les européens ont ainsi accès
au plus grand nombre de vaccins ou un
plus grand nombre de vaccins que
l'essentiel des citoyens des autres pays
chacun de ces vaccins a par ailleurs
fait l'objet d'une validation rigoureuse
par une autorité indépendante qui
garantit la sécurité et l'efficacité de
ces produits de nouveaux laboratoires
janssen et novavax viennent d'entrer en
discussions avec l' agence du médicament
européen et espère obtenir l'approbation
de leurs vaccins dans les prochaines
semaines en parallèle nous nous sommes
assurés pour chacun de ces vaccins que
la production puisse être réalisé en
europe
l'enjeu est de garantir dans la durée
notre indépendance d'approvisionnement
c'est ainsi que l'essentiel des doses
aujourd'hui qui sont acheminés vers la
france sont produites en europe et en
europe compte tenu de ses perspectives
je peux donc vous confirmez que la
france sera en situation de vacciner
tous les adultes qui le souhaite d'ici
la fin de l'été comme cela a été indiqué
par le président de la république et par
le premier ministre je veux également re
dire une chose mettre au point des
vaccins efficaces et fabriquer des
millions de doses en moins d'un an est
une prouesse scientifique technologique
et industrielle cela n'a jamais été
réalisé
de mémoire d'homme nous sommes
maintenant dans une phase de montée en
puissance de la production
cette montée en puissance de la
duction conditionne l'augmentation de
nos livraisons
cette phase de massification de la
fabrication et notamment les transferts
de technologies qui sont nécessaires
sont une phase délicate et critique
si pour cela qu'il faut s'attendre à des
phases de mise au point de
ralentissement puis d'accélération des
productions dans les sites de
fabrication comme nous l'avons vécue
récemment dans les sites de bayod ntech
de moderna et d'astrazeneca
ces tensions sur la production sont
traités par les équipes européennes et
par les équipes françaises avec la plus
grande fermeté ce qui est paraît
évidemment normal
d'abord nous travaillons étroitement
avec les laboratoires et les industriels
pour les aider à augmenter leurs
capacités de production à multiplier les
lieux de production
c'est le sens de la réunion qui s'est
tenue mardi soir autour du président de
la république
deuxièmement nous contrôlons et auditons
les usines en particulier celles qui
peuvent présenter des difficultés pour
nous assurer et prendre la mesure de ses
difficultés à accompagner les
industriels
troisièmement nous contrôlons désormais
les doses est exportée en dehors de
l'union européenne enfin nous veillons à
ce que les contrats soient respectés et
que les doses qui ne peuvent être livrés
depuis les usines européennes soit le
cas échéant livré depuis d'autres sites
de production il y à la négociation sur
les livraisons et la négociation sur les
sites de production il ne faut pas
mélanger les deux nous devons maintenant
mobiliser toutes les entreprises qui en
ont la capacité pour produire des
vaccins produire un vaccin ou un nouveau
vaccin pour des milliards de personnes
qui est un concentré de connaissances
scientifiques et qui repose pour les
vaccins arn messager comme celui dont
nous disposons
aujourd'hui ce dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui dayot ntech et moderna c'est
à dire des technologies nouvelles
ça ne se fait pas en claquant dans les
doigts il faut habituellement 18 à 30
mois pour réaliser ce travail
la france contribuera à produire dès les
prochains mois
quatre vaccins en france le moderna à
partir du mois de mars le bâillon ntech
à partir du mois d'avril
le curve ac si ce vaccin reçoit son
autorisation de mise sur le marché à
partir du mois de mai et le sanofi à
partir du mois de juin ceci le fruit
d'un travail entamé dès juin dernier
2020 par le gouvernement s'agissant des
vaccins moderna by one tech et curve ac
puisque nous avons accompagné et financé
les lignes de production dans trois
sites industriels français qui vont
accueillir ses productions sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république nous continuons à mobiliser
les laboratoires et les industriels pour
mettre en place de nouvelles capacités
de production
l'engagement de sanofi à produire 100
millions de doses en 2021 pour bayod
ntech annoncé courant janvier est un
exemple de coopération que nous avons
organisés que nous souhaitons renouveler
pour ce faire un commando vaccins sous
ma responsabilité directe qui réunit des
experts du privé et du public est en
contact permanent avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de la production afin de
mobiliser tous les leviers pour produire
plus et plus vite nous le faisons en
lien avec la commission européenne qui
vient d'annoncer la mise en place d'une
task force d'industrialisation et de
soutien à la production de vaccin sous
l'égide des commissaires kyriakides s
est breton tous les laboratoires et
sous-traitants sur le territoire
national ont répondu présents pour
participer à cette mission
c'est grâce à cette méthode d'action
coordonnée que les pings les pays
l'union européenne sortiront ensemble de
cette crise qui ne connaît pas de
frontières merci beaucoup
madame la ministre mes chers concitoyens
gérer une crise sanitaire une crise
inédite
une crise qui évolue à l'image des
variances est forcément concilier
plusieurs paramètres
plusieurs critères et rechercher le bon
point d'équilibré en sachant que
celui-ci évolue nécessairement au fil du
temps et de l'évolution de la maladie
elle même mais de tous ces critères à
prendre en compte celui que nous avons
toujours privilégié c'est le critère
sanitaires c'est la protection de votre
santé ce critère doit être le premier et
il doit le rester
même s'il nous conduit parfois à prendre
des décisions impopulaires
c'est là notre responsabilité et
j'entends l'assumé pleinement
comme je les ai toujours fait mais en
veillant toujours à bien prendre en
compte aussi les conséquences de
décisions sur toutes celles et ceux qui
en subissent les effets directement ou
indirectement
c'est le sens des mesures que nous avons
prises et ajustés au cours des derniers
mois et des dernières semaines pour nous
mettre en capacité de maîtriser
l'évolution du virus
ces mesures ont vocation à se poursuivre
c'est pourquoi nous avons intensifié et
nous allons encore adapté des mesures
d'accompagnement économique social
psychologique
jamais la solidarité nationale envers
eux et plus généralement envers tous nos
concitoyens qui sont dans la souffrance
matérielle et humaine n'a pris autant
son sens
et croyez moi lorsqu'on regarde ce qui
se passe ailleurs
la france n'a pas à rougir loin s'en
fout bien loin en tout cas des
éternelles critiques et de
l'autoflagellation à laquelle nous c'est
donc trop souvent nous avons besoin d'un
effort collectif fort de civisme je
dirais même d'une mobilisation générale
pour que nous fassions reculer le virus
les vacances d'hiver débutent pour
certaines zones
demain soir nous avons choisi de ne pas
limiter les déplacements entre régions
une telle mesure aurait été juste
si fier si la circulation du virus était
très inégale selon les régions ce n'est
pas le cas pour autant plus que jamais
nous devons éviter tout relâchement
comme vous l'avez fait l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année je vous invite à la
plus grande prudence durant ses congés
pour celles et ceux d'entre vous qui
pouvez en prendre vous faire tester vous
i doser au moindre doute appliquer les
gestes barrière respecter des règles
communes
plus que jamais ces bonnes pratiques
quotidiennes sont au coeur du combat
contre la pandémie
surtout si nous avons la volonté commune
d'éviter un nouveau confinement c'est à
dire de fermer nos commerces où nos
écoles
surtout si nous avons la volonté commune
de soulager nos soignants et nos
services hospitaliers nous sommes
engagés depuis des mois les chers
concitoyens dans un long combat un
combat qui va durer qui n'est pas
terminée qui suppose résistance et
persévérance sens de la solidarité et
des responsabilités et je sais que nous
en sommes parfaitement capables nous
l'avons prouvé et nous le prouverons
encore il faut tenir ensemble je vous
remercie et nous nous tenons prêts
mesdames et messieurs avec ministre à
répondre à vos questions
bonjour le hic besson bfm tv mais c'est
le premier ministre que dites vous aux
français qui s'apprêtent à partir en
vacances et qui ont peur d'un nouveau
confinement pendant qu'ils y sont parce
que vous avez parlé de la situation
elle est constante mais elle est
progressive en terme de contamination
dont de plus en plus de variants
susceptible de tout accéléré il ya déjà
des centres hospitaliers qui s'apprête à
des programmes et à partir de quel seuil
précis estimez-vous qu'un nouveau
confinement se justifierait et puis j'en
profite pour demander une petite
précision sur les contrôles aux
frontières terrestres parce que c'est
une question que beaucoup se posent
que se passe-t-il lorsque quelqu'un se
présente sans tester ce qu'il reçoit
juste une amende ou bien est-ce qu'il
est refoulé tester et peut être isolé de
manière contrainte
merci beaucoup une deuxième question
puis on va répondre
bras monsieur le premier ministre
bonjour camille collin pour tf1 lci j'ai
d'abord une question justement sur les
consignes sanitaires
diriez-vous aujourd'hui que les gestes
barrière scrupuleusement respecté
pourrait être finalement plus efficace
ou tout du moins aussi efficace avec 1
re confinement et puis sur le variant
angles est une étude de l'inserm
notamment prévoit que le variant anglais
soit prennent le pas sur la souche qui
circulent actuellement en france à la
fin du mois au début du mois de mars
est ce que ce serait dans ce scénario
est bien une condition justement de
confinement pour rejoindre la question
nos collègues merci merci beaucoup
donc je vais demander au ministre des
solidarités de la santé de venir me
rejoindre puisque l'essentiel des
questions s'adressent à lui puis nous
viendrons à la question du contrôle aux
frontières terrestres
monsieur le ce qu'il faut qui était
vraiment important de comprendre c'est
que ce qu'on veut éviter c'est une
épidémie dans l'épidémie vous avez
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 qu'on connaît
bien le corona virus qui sévit depuis un
an en france et dans le monde
on en connaît les caractéristiques on en
connaît la contagiosité est il ya
l'apparition de ces variants il ya
beaucoup de variantes qui peuvent
émerger dans un virus comme le co vide
mais certains on n'en parle pas parce
qu'ils sont moins contagieux ou autant
contagieux il ne se font pas leur place
au sein de l'épidémie mondiale
et puis certains parce qu'ils sont
justement plus contagieux circule plus
vite et prennent petit à petit de
l'importance là où ils circulent jusqu'à
devenir majoritaire est la question que
vous posez au fond et c'est là qu'ils
ont la question que nous travaillons
constamment au quotidien avec les
scientifiques sur la base de l'observer
à l'étranger le portugal l'espagne
l'angleterre l'irlande l'allemagne tous
ces pays qui sont en confinement avec
une des épidémies qui font rage
la question c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
effectivement si le variant qui est plus
contagion plus au cottage vieux pardon
devient majoritaire
c'est le risque de la vague épidémique
que nous voulons à tout prix éviter
raison pour laquelle il y a le
couvre-feu de 18h raison pour laquelle
il ya le renforcement des mesures de
gestion comme la fermeture des
frontières l'augmentation du télétravail
tout ce que nous pouvons faire et tous
ces gestes du quotidien
le respect des gestes barrières qui
éteint le
et puissants je ne dirais pas qu'il est
plus important et plus et plus efficace
que le confinement
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que plus nous
respectons les gestes barrière plus nous
éloignons la menace d'une épidémie qui
justifierait de prendre des mesures de
restriction collective comme un
confinement
donc c'est vraiment ça et donc on
surveille on voit que pour l'instant
effectivement le variant anglais
notamment il augmente petit à petit dans
d'autres pays le besoin d'environ 50%
par semaine grâce au couvre-feu entre
guillemets il n'augmente que de 50% par
semaine au portugal par exemple ils
augmentent entre 80 et 100% par semaine
en tout cas avant qu'ils aient mis en
place un confinement
donc ce qu'on veut c'est le freiner le
plus longtemps possible à mesure qu'on
le frêne le temps que nous gagnons sur
la montée du variant nous permet de
vacciner davantage de personnes près de
2 millions d'injections été réalisés à
ce soir nous allons amplifier continuer
à mesure les deux arrivent comme
l'expliquait à une espagnole une hache
et puis nous protégeons les plus
fragiles plus éloigné le risque que s'il
devait y avoir véritablement une
épidémie de variants elle n'emporte des
conséquences sanitaires importantes dans
la population
donc c'est vraiment ça c'est une idée
d'une course contre la montre chaque
jour que nous gagnons sans avoir
d'explosion du variant est un jour qui
nous permet de protéger davantage de
personnes les conditions météo seront
meilleurs aussi au fur et à mesure des
semaines on sait que le virus circule
manifestement moins facilement quand les
joueurs sont meilleurs là actuellement
nous avons plutôt une belle période
d'ailleurs en france donc c'est ça c'est
vraiment ça quand on dit de tenir
ensemble c'est sa remise intérieure pour
les contrôles aux frontières terrestres
mais alors il ya plusieurs types
effectivement de car d'abord à ses
frontières terrestres ce qu'il s'agit de
citoyens français français binational ou
français évidemment nous ne pouvons pas
refouler les citoyens français même s'il
n'avait pas de test et qui voudraient
rentrer sur le territoire national mais
évidemment une amende est prise ainsi
effectivement qu'une incitation très
forte à s'isoler
s'il s'agit de personnes qui est en
dehors de l'union européenne ou de
citoyens européens mais qui ne sont pas
des frontaliers nous pouvons une
instruction du premier ministre va être
prise et le droit européen ne le permet
évitez les admissions sur le sol
national et donc ne pas les faire
rentrer sur le territoire national et
puis évidemment une des exceptions que
j'évoquais les
montagné et les routiers qui ne sont pas
soumis à ce sujet même s'ils peuvent
effectivement être contrôlés dans le
flux des passages terrestres des
véhicules
je rappelle d'ailleurs que pour les
étrangers qui viendrait de l'extérieur
de l'union européenne il peut être de ne
pas être amis du tout sur le territoire
national et réadmis dans leur pays
c'est le cas notamment évidemment dans
le cas des aéroports ou dans des grands
trafics internationaux
oui je invendus ou c'est d'abord je
voudrais redire que par rapport aux
vacances je voudrais répondre à une
question que vous ne m'avez pas posée
puisque vous avez dans cette question
évoqué la perspective d'un confinement
qui surviendrait pendant que les gens
sont en vacances qui est une perspective
qu'on ne peut pas effectivement exclure
notre intention bien sûr et d'autoriser
les genres gagner dans ces conditions
leur domicile puis ça parce que c est
une question qui n'a pas posé mais qui
revient de manière régulière et que je
voulais donc clarifié devant vous
pourtant monsieur le premier ministre je
un niveau d'eau pour un repas il ya eu
donc de ces derniers jours une promesse
de vaccination pour tous les adultes à
l'été est ce que cette promesse ne
risque pas de créer des déceptions à ce
qu'il n'y a pas un risque de déception
est finalement un risque politique à
faire ce type de promesses vous en
seriez ainsi que le président comptable
et puis pour compléter la question de
mon confrère de bfm tv sur un possible
confinement on comprend donc que cette
option est possible vous avez noté
probablement l'anxiété que la tante
l'incertitude crèche de très nombreux
français on avec une séquence il ya une
dizaine de jours où on a tous
collectivement cru qu'il y aurait un
recond finement imminent ont dit
certains ou en recrutement serré a dit
notamment l'un de vos ministres
est-ce que vous donnerez des signes dans
les jours précédents je fais juste une
parenthèse pour dire que ce n'était pas
uniquement la presse qui est inventé ça
ce que la presse a relayé c'était
évidemment les conseillers les ministres
qui en parle merci beaucoup
bonjour messieurs le premier lille
jérémy marot de la fp quelques questions
justes pour les services de de la fp
vous tablez sur 4 millions de personnes
vaccinées à la fin février des chiffres
qu'on
dont on dispose on comprend que 8
millions de doses seront reçus par la
france à cette période là comment est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer ce delta même si
l'on comprend bien qu'une partie de ces
doses de ce delta sera pour la deuxième
injection
une question sur les traitements est ce
qu'il y a des espoirs en la matière est
ce que la recherche française qui me
taire un peu plus à la peine sur les
vaccins à des espoirs d'être cette fois
ci en pointe sur la question des
traitements et enfin vous avait annoncé
500 milles rendez vous qui seront
ouverts d'ici demain
est ce que ce sont les 500 milles mêmes
qui avaient été annoncées qui aurait dû
être ouvert la semaine dernière
très bien j'invite le ministre sentez
parce que l'essentiel des questions le
concerne simplement par rapport à
question d'europe 1 sur leur confinement
par confinement que vous avez évoquées
en réalité ce qui crée de l'anxiété 1
messieurs dames comme toujours c'est le
virus et ses incertitudes
donc effectivement face à la situation
actuelle qu'il y a eu des interrogations
je n'ai fait état dans mon intervention
je les dis vendredi sur la perspective
où la possibilité de re confiné je vous
le confirme vous le confirme j'ai
également indiqué nous avons dit que
malheureusement cette perspective il
n'avait pas disparu
simplement pour toutes les raisons que
nous avons dit il faut nous donner
collectivement les moyens de l'éviter et
de tout faire pour qu'elle ne se
produise pas parce que nous soyons tous
bien d'accord il y a je l'entends des
personnes qui sont favorables
or confinement mais pas favorables aux
mesures que ce recompte finement
entraînera nécessairement on les connaît
maintenant malheureusement nous avons
une grande expérience qu'est ce qu'il
reste à fermer les commerces qui ne sont
pas des commerces vendant des des
services ou des biens dits de première
nécessité mais vous savez déjà qu'avec
le couvre-feu à 18 heures avec les
mesures que j'ai annoncée vendredi
dernier
et sur les très grands centres
commerciaux on a déjà joué si j'ose dire
sur ce levier puis après il ya des
établissements scolaires bon donc il
faut bien comprendre et admettre que
toutes ces dispositions entraînent des
conséquences y compris sanitaires y
compris sanitaires y compris
psychologique qui sent très dur même à
laisser de côté les questions
économiques puisque je voulais dire je
l'assumé le sanitaire d'abord il y à des
questions qui se posent
il y a des interrogations liées
effectivement au virus en fait qu'ils
varient
pour l'instant nous avons dit il n'y a
pas nécessité de re confiné appliquons
tous ensemble tous les leviers à notre
disposition pour essayer d'éviter cette
perspective je pense qu'il serait tout
aussi malhonnête de dire qu'elle est
définitivement écartée voilà c'est fait
je crois aussi que faire par année
nos concitoyens des questionnements qui
se posent des incertitudes il ya c'est
aussi gérer dans la transparence
cette épidémie c'est ne pas les
infantiliser garde et voilà nous
essayons de prendre à un moment
déterminé les meilleures décisions
possibles pour vous protéger et pour
prévenir la progression des piscines
monsieur lisa santé de questions je
crois qu'il m'était adressé un sur le
nombre de vaccinés à la fin du mois de
février souvenez-vous nous avions dit
qu'il y aurait entre 2,4 et 4 millions
de français qui recevraient une première
injection de vaccin d'ici à fin février
nous serons entre 3,5 et 4 millions de
français qui auront reçu une première
injection à la fin du mois de février
et vous l'avez dit vous-même il ya des
rappels de vaccination je vous donne les
chiffres de ce soir un million sept cent
soixante six mille premières injections
ont été faites dans notre pays
189 mille rappel de vaccination ont été
réalisés c'est à dire près de 2 millions
d'injections
mais à mesure que le temps que les
semaines sans chaînes le nombre de
rappels de vaccination va devenir de
plus en plus important et lorsque nous
aurons plus de dos c'est à dire au mois
de mars on pourra augmenter encore le
nombre
primo injection donc les chiffres sont
bons et je rappelle que nous ne gardons
aucune aucun vaccin dans aucun centre
national tout est déployé dans les
territoires je vous donne un exemple
nous serons livrés normalement demain
soir avec les premières doses
d'astrazeneca 250 mille doses de vaccin
astrazeneca après demain c'est d'eau
seront dispatchés dans les 100 hôpitaux
qui vont du territoire national et j'ai
réunis ce midi l'ensemble du monde
hospitalier qui gère et qui pilote la
politique de vaccination en visio je
vous rassure et des jeux aurait demandé
à ce que dès samedi après-midi les
vaccinations de soignants âgées de 65
ans et moins avec le astrazeneca puisse
démarrer
donc on sera pour le coup dans un
démarrage extrêmement extrêmement rapide
parce que tout est prêt et tout est mis
en place et ça fonctionne bien
deuxième question vous avez posé c'est
sur les traitements les perspectives
thérapeutiques n'êtes pas sans savoir
que le président de la république a
réuni les restes des responsables du
monde de la santé des grands
scientifiques mais également les agences
sanitaires ainsi qu'était laboratoire
pour envisager avec eux l'ensemble des
traitements qui pourraient être
intéressants et qui pourrait être
intéressant de tester aussi notamment
sur le territoire national dans les
jours et les semaines à venir de ces
réunions extrêmement extrêmement
productives ont germé un certain nombre
de pistes thérapeutiques
je pense notamment à ce qu'on appelle
des anticorps monoclonaux c'est des
médicaments complexes mais qui
permettent dans des études publiées
notamment aux états unis de réduire
l'apparition de formes graves chez des
publics particulièrement fragile nous
sommes en train d'avancer sur le terrain
nous avançons rapidement il y aura des
annonces qui seront faites prochainement
c'est pas tout de suite ce soir mais ça
viendra bientôt merci les deux dernières
questions
monsieur le premier ministre
mathieu des moulins pour tf1 lci deux
questions d'abord sur la réouverture des
restaurants et des lieux culturels
l'italie a été en mesure de donner une
date récemment est-ce qu'à défaut de
donner une date de réouverture vous
pouvez au moins leur donner une
perspective d'éclaircies et puis une
question si sur les vacances je vous
avais parlé d'un appel à la prudence
mais les français pourront
éventuellement être confrontés à des
embouteillages liés au chassé-croisé
entre les différentes zones
le week-end dernier plusieurs personnes
coincées dans les bouchons ont été
verbalisés ce qu'à l'occasion d'un
chassé-croisé il y aura une tolérance
merci beaucoup bonsoir mon vin cluzel
pourrait lancer une petite précision
concernant notamment les variantes
brésilien vous avez annoncé plusieurs
cas détecté en france est ce que vous
nous expliquer d'où venaient ces
personnes s qui revenait d'un voyage à
l'étranger
est-ce que des cas contacts ont été
recensés suite à cette détection par
ailleurs est ce que on sait si le vaccin
astrazeneca et efficace par rapport à ce
variant brésilien et sud-africains une
toute dernière précision le vaccin sera
zeneca pour l'instant n'est pas
recommandé pour les plus de 65 ans vous
attendiez des données plus précises
est ce que vous savez à peu près quand
vous pourrez avoir des nouvelles données
qui permettraient de d'éclaircir ce
point
merci merci beaucoup
alors je demande au ministre de la santé
de s'approcher à nouveau simplement sur
les lieux culturels et les restaurants
et les perspectives qui ont été demandés
bon donc c'est clair pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de perspective à court terme
bon nous travaillons
avec eux parce que les ministres
concernés les prochaines nous disent
souvent écoutée on préférerait que vous
nous donniez une perspective même très
éloignées plutôt que d'aller d'état
panetta j'ai déjà indiqué en tout cas
que je lui dis pas ce que vous pourriez
aussi posé la question pour les stations
de ski
je leur ai dit que de toute façon le
mois de février était définitivement
compromis la seule chose que je suis en
mesure de vous dire c'est que la
ministre de la culture roselyne bachelot
travail avec les professionnels est sans
doute à établir une distinction entre
les établissements une vie culturelle du
circulant quand c'est à dire pas où on
est assis
dans un lieu clos par exemple les musées
où on pourrait avoir effectivement dans
ce souci de prévisibilité une ouverture
plus anticipé de crp que d autres
d'accord donc ceci on y travaille on va
essayer de redonner de la visibilité
mais vous comprenez que la situation
actuelle un calme ou trouvant ne serait
pas raisonnable de ma part de parler de
réouverture déjanire là pour le coup n'y
comprendraient plus rien bon donc oui à
des travaux pour donner des perspectives
non pour annoncer ce soir des dates
précises
monsieur le ministre sentez en train de
regarder une situation pratique pour
pouvoir être précis sur la question du
variant parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant de voir comment fonctionnent
les équipes des ars et l'assurance
maladie quand je devais mettre des
images des chiffres derrière ce qu'on
appelle le contact racing par exemple il
ya un des cas de variants brésiliens
identifiés qui est une femme qui
revenait de manaus au brésil où vous
savez que sévit une épidémie importante
avec du variant brésilien n est pas
rentré directement en france elle a fait
manaus sao paulo san paolo francfort
francfort paris paris marseille elle
avait été testée avant le départ
quelques jours auparavant mais est
arrivé en allemagne en l'occurrence et
pas en france
le détail est important parce que les
protocoles n'était pas forcément
identique
elle a présenté des symptômes peu après
son arrivée en france étaient testés
s'est révélée positive comme il y avait
une alerte sur la possibilité qu'il y
ait des variants brésilien c'était les
premiers jours où il était vraiment
question de ces variants elle a été mise
en isolement en stricte avec visite
d'une infirmière à domicile
interventions des cellules territoriales
d'appui l isolement j'en parlais tout à
l'heure pour apporter tout le soutien
sanitaire social et vérifier que les
conditions étaient bonnes le contact
racing a été fait par la grèce
immédiatement une autre personne a été
identifiée qui avait voyagé avec elle
qui a également été isolés comme cas
contacts et un certain nombre de cas
contacts autour de ces deux personnes
ont été placés à l'isolément le temps de
pouvoir tester tout le monde et en
l'occurrence n'ya pas de chaîne de
contamination
un autre cas de variants de personnes
atteintes de variantes brésilien je le
disais dans la région auvergne rhône
alpes est une personne qui
avait voyagé et qui travaillent dans les
hôpitaux de genève
donc la rs cette fois-ci de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes à identifier
immédiatement des cas contacts au sein
de l'hôpital où cette personne travaille
dix personnes sont positives en attente
de recherche de variants et à chaque
fois qu'il ya une suspicion parce qu'il
ya un déplacement au post ya eu un
contact avec une personne qui était en
déplacement dans une zone où on peut
trouver du variant non seulement
isolement est vraiment strict avec un
accompagnement important mais il est
procédé un séquençage génétique
c'est-à-dire que une fois que le pcr est
positive le test est positif on va
vérifier s'il s'agit du variant ou non
dans le doute on fait comme si c'était
un variant et lorsque c'est confirmé
bien on l'annoncent comme je laissais là
tout ce qui a été fait il ya à peu près
un an dans notre
non maintenant à contamines montjoie si
vous vous en souvenez en haute savoie
quand je dis qu'on considère ces
variantes comme des quasiment des
nouveaux virus c'est que on les traite
comme si c'était des virus qui jusqu'ici
n'étaient pas encore en circulation sur
le territoire
c'était plus le cas pour le variant
anglais on y prête une attention
particulière mais on a davantage
d'éléments et d'information je le disais
et pour le variant sud africains
originaires du sud afrique du sud et le
variant brésilien on les traite
véritablement comme des nouveaux virus à
part bien monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur pour les questions de
d'embouteillage ou de tolérance aux
embouteillages
et puis nous arrêterons là oui très
rapidement monsieur le premier ministre
il est évident que chacun doit respecter
la règle est que cette règle fait qu'à
18 heures il ya un couvre feu et se
couvre feu c'est la situation la plus
satisfaisante je mets évidemment des
guillemets pour éviter les mesures de
confinement plus plus plus strictes et
que si l'attitude est laissée aux forces
de l'ordre pour entendre des excuses des
difficultés de sécurité routière que
l'on peut comprendre qu'on a parfois
constatée évidemment elles ne peuvent
pas être une règle générale est dictée
devant vous donc à partir des la grance
comme en dehors des vacances il faut
savoir respecter le fait qu'à 18 heures
c'est aux français de s'organiser il
faut être arrivé à son lieu de
destination de même que nous fermons un
certain nombre de lieux de commerce ou
de l'activité professionnelle souvent 18
heures c'est le moment
non pas qu'on doit partir moment on doit
arriver alors l'attestation et les
papiers qui en général accompagne cette
attestation pour montrer qu'il ya des
contre-exemples et le prouver évidemment
forces de l'ordre mais je souhaite
effectivement que cela sur le plus
régler possible dans une latitude
laissée aux forces de l'ordre dans le
bon sens qui les caractérise merci
beaucoup
toutes et à tous